one modern woman demonizes anything that
is uh
that detriment to her so for example as
us as men when we're young we realize
that
all right when you're like 16 you
realize the local drugs who's like 19
will pull up in the vauxhall corsa will
take the sexiest girl of the year and
you just have to take it because you're
young and that's it and that's just the
game is the game
you see women when they hit
like say touching 30 they'll go out to
clubs and they'll say
why is everyone in here a kid or they'll
start demonizing men of their age who
are dating 23 year olds like oh why
can't you get a woman your age and they
don't accept that power dividers now
because okay once you see this you can't
really unsee it every time men have a
standard women shame them for it body
count yeah so every time so the things
that men value they're shamed for
valuing
so so for example if a guy says i want a
young girl i want her to be in shape i
want no kids
they're saying you're fat phobic you're
slut-shaming
but girls can go on a public platform
and say i deserve this this this and
this and nobody bouts and i
i like i deserve a guy that treats me
right i deserve a guy that makes this
amount of money i deserve a guy that's
this tall and no one will say anything
okay where do you think that comes from
i just think society is geared towards
women we make 70 to 80 percent of
consumer buying decisions so i just
think everything in the media is for
women except this channel like the video
i think part of it is
women are sold this narrative from such
a young age that you can be whatever you
want and it doesn't matter so like for
example body positivity
um
body count doesn't matter whereas for
men
if you're
short bold in fat and you're broke
there's no support group for broke men
there's no support group for fat men
other than weight watchers in cell
yeah could it also be like but even even
insult right that's that's like a term
to to shame men or make fun of them it's
like derogatory but if a girl's fat
there's a whole movement to put her on
the cover of a magazine nobody's trying
yeah no one's trying to put the the
short broken men on the cover of
magazines yeah because i try to kill
people what say it again
i try to kick can i say that one yeah
because i'm trying to kill people
they're trying to kill people maybe
inside oh it's generally associated with
that
i'll move on but yeah i think for women
like the the feminism movement came from
because of
feminazi movement yeah
like
i'm not the feminazi movement but
the the
feminism movement came from women that
were repressed and unhappy and had been
sold
this belief that they were only due this
in life
this is all you need to
find a suitable husband get married have
children and that is your lot and be
happy with it so did you know that
feminism was actually started by men
no
it started in um seneca falls in new
york and it had um
200 men 100 women there okay
and to me feminism is and always has
been freedom without responsibility
starting with the right to vote
because most women didn't actually want
the right to vote because it came with
getting drafted if today in 2022 there
was a war and you had to pick do i want
to vote
in society but if i vote i go and fight
to war
or
you can or you cannot vote
and not have to go to war i've often
wanted to go to war you want to be
fighting in the front line my dad was in
the sas
[Music]
so front lines
maybe yeah you don't know like how do
you know i like fighting
i personally i'm i'm in the kitchen i'm
not i'm not brave i'm not
maybe
something yeah but i'm saying like the
most women didn't want the freedom
because it came with responsibility so
feminism came in and said screw it
anyone can vote even if you don't have
the responsibility that comes with it
and so every time it's even with um with
birth control right you get the freedom
to sleep around going against biology
without the responsibility of the kid
because you can put the data on child
support that's a fail safe
okay and then on top of that you can
also get money from the government
that's a fail-safe yeah
so
and so women are incentivized to get
kids off of rich guys i'm not saying
i'll do some get them off of broke eyes
i don't
but
but but it do you see so we keep putting
these laws in that take away the
responsibility from women and give us
more freedom but i don't think it's
making us happy because
the the
most unhappy demographic graphic is
women that are single childless and over
the age of 45 life gets pretty lonely
yeah after a certain age or not you're
gonna look weird in the clubs
you're gonna look weird going out and
like but is it not a natural progression
of society for us to
seek different relationships rather than
just let's be married and have kids well
if we keep seeking different
relationships and not having kids then
the older generation is going to die off
and there's not going to be a new
generation to fill the needs that we
need to keep the society i'm not sorry
i'm inviting children is that positive
too like oh mumsy got jilled by me down
the road no i didn't mean like multiple
different relationships i meant
relationships that were happy and rather
than something that is expected of you
because we are in a war and and you need
to have a man at home and a woman i mean
sorry a man out and a woman at home like
different relationships in terms of one
that you're happy in do you that's what
people expect now right to be happy
rather than just to put up with a man
that is
your husband for
do you think relationships are about
happiness
oh
is it like them to be
do you think in 50 years if you want to
be married to someone like let's say you
got married tomorrow you live to be 80
50 your marriage
um
but is it realistic to expect you're
going to be happy all 50 years
no but
now it's not expected that you stay in
an unhappy relationship generations
before yes because there are many
reasons not just because well i think
generations before would laugh at us to
be honest i think the wives from the
1950s would laugh at us when we leave
because we're not happy because you know
she's like i had a whole side chick
across town he had a whole second family
and you guys are leaving because you're
not happy
do you all come from happy homes with
parents that stay together
i mean not um
yeah i mean i did i have two parents
they have 10 kids
and um i mean they weren't always happy
though
and so what i would see is like growing
up my friends parents would be unhappy
and they decided to get divorced and it
didn't it wasn't really great for the
kids where my parents there were times
when they were unhappy and they just
figured it out
and just you know because because to
them it was always about us it wasn't
about their happiness it was about us i
can attest to that um
my
my grandmother
um
her my grandfather had a family across
town she stayed with him i always asked
like well why didn't you leave and she's
like i just stayed with them i had kids
with them that was my husband and he had
the other family and it wasn't like she
didn't know about them or anything she
just stayed and that's something that's
very taboo nowadays to stay with someone
that has a family across town i think
it's just
easier for us to be like i don't like it
i don't want it i'm going to choose
something else
i think we've become quite
individualistic as a culture so we don't
maybe think about the community or the
bigger picture or like like raising the
next generation so you you put yourself
first and your own like
happiness first yes so i think